Good evening, everyone.
Well, tonight we're going to start a
series that is going to be hair-raising.
Because the book of Revelation is the
story about the final conflict
between the forces of good and forces of
evil.
It also has the history of the conflict
from the birth of Christianity to the
end of time. It really is an incredible
book.
And of course, the ultimate author book
is none other than Jesus Christ himself.
We are living in an incredible time.
We are living in a time
when Jesus is to be made less and less.
I believe we are living in the most
serious times in the history of the
world.
And this is going to be
exciting.
Now, we can do this
the gentle way
or we can do it the straight way.
And I believe that we are living in
times where there isn't time to have the
soft approach.
So, what I intend to do in the next 2
weeks
is to tell you
what the book of Revelation has to say.
And some of it might be a little bit
disturbing,
but I want you to remember
that if you've led read the last verses,
then Jesus gets to win.
So, there is really nothing to worry
about. It might create fear in the
hearts of some when you see what is
happening in the world and how these
things have been planned
for centuries.
And yet,
God foretold it all in the minutest
detail a long, long time ago.
Surely, that shows that he's in control,
right or wrong?
He is in control.
They've even tried to remove it from the
word of God.
So, there's been a battle over the word
of God
through the centuries, culminating in
the mightiest battle that no one really
knows about in our very time. And we'll
be looking at that issue as well. There
are some lectures coming up. We'll be
looking at this very issue.
How they distorted things and changed
things so that you may not recognize
the peril that we are actually in.
So, the book of Revelation
is a story
about beauty.
It's a story about truth. It's a story
about restoration. It is the story about
the victory of God over all the enemies
of God. It's the story of the setting up
of the kingdom of God, which will exist
forever and ever and ever without tear
or pain or death. It really is an
amazing story, and there is nothing, but
nothing to fear
if we have God on our side. Now, in my
own personal life,
I used to be an atheist.
Scientists at the world in the big
worldly universities, total atheist. My
wife comes from a spiritualistic
background.
Her family was into the New Age
movement. So, esotericism on the one
side, atheism on the other side. My
parents were very, very religious,
and uh
I hated religion. I wanted nothing to do
with it.
And today I walk all over the world, all
over the globe,
and I preach the message of Jesus
Christ, and I talk about creation, and I
believe every word as it is written in
the word of God.
Not only
do I believe it because I believe it's
logical and it is written to be
understood, but I can guarantee you that
over the years I've experienced it, and
I know that my God lives, and I know
that he cares about every single one of
us, and he doesn't want us to be in
darkness. He wants us to know. That's
why the book is called the Revelation of
Jesus Christ. Some people say it's a
hidden revelation. There's no such thing
as a hidden revelation. Either something
is revealed
or it's hidden, but it cannot be both.
It is a revelation.
And the Revelation of Jesus Christ is
the most amazing book
in the Bible.
It ends the biblical story.
In the beginning, we have the book of
Genesis. In Genesis, we have the lost
tree of life. Mankind fell into sin and
lost access to the tree of life.
The consequences were death. Genesis
chapter 2 verse 17.
And from that moment on, man had to earn
his bread by the sweat of his brow.
Genesis chapter 3 verse 19. Man lost his
dominion because he was created to have
dominion,
and he became naked. He lost the robe of
righteousness, which covered him.
And then he was driven from God because
sin and a holy God are incompatible.
That's the story of Genesis. It's the
sad story
of the creation of man and the fall of
man.
The greatest gift to mankind that God
could have given is the gift of freedom
of choice.
Without freedom of choice, we are
robots.
And so, God created man in the image of
God with the capacity to choose. And
love demands this gift of freedom of
choice. I always use an example. What
good is it
if your wife or your husband loves you
because he's pre-programmed to do so?
That might be fun for a week, a year,
maybe even 5 years, but then eventually,
you'll get kind of sick of it, right?
If they're programmed to love you, and
every morning they get up and they say,
"I love you." because they're programmed
to do so.
But what happens
if they have freedom of choice, and in
spite of your faults, in spite of all
the things that you do that are
obviously uh
an irritation to everyone around you?
What if they still say, "I love you."
because they choose to? Doesn't that
make it meaningful?
Without freedom of choice, life is
meaningless. So, God created man in his
image with the capacity to choose.
That's special.
And so, man chose,
and unfortunately, he chose the wrong
way.
Revelation is the book of grace.
In Revelation chapter 2 verse 7, we read
about the restoration
of the tree of life.
We read about victory over a death in
Revelation chapter 2 verse 11.
We read about hidden manna. This is uh
the bread that came from heaven that was
placed in the ark of the covenant and
represented this heavenly bread, which
would take away your hunger forever, and
that was replaced, and we read about it
in Revelation chapter 2 verse 17.
Dominion would be restored. Revelation 2
verse 26.
Those that accepted this wonderful gift
from God would be clothed in white. So,
the lost robe of righteousness would be
restored. Revelation 3 verse 5.
And no more separation from God.
Revelation 3 verse 12. So, the book of
Revelation
is a book of restoration.
But it also has information in it
which is scary, to put it bluntly.
Scary.
The structure of the book. There are
seven churches, seven letters, seven
stars, seven candlesticks, seven
spirits, seven lamps, seven seals, seven
trumpets, seven horns, seven eyes, seven
thunders, seven heads, seven crowns,
seven angels, seven vials, and seven
mountains. So, the number seven is
obviously important. The number seven is
the the number of the divine. It's the
number of perfection. It is the message
of God built in.
But, there is a counterfeit as well.
And we will be dealing with that as we
go along.
And obviously, if we look at all these
components, then there is a symbolic
meaning in all of these as well. So, the
Book of Revelation uses symbolic
language. And where does it get the
symbolic language from?
It draws it from the Old Testament.
So, without the Old Testament, we would
not be able to understand the Book of
Revelation. Many of the symbols in the
Book of Revelation come, for example,
from Zechariah, from Ezekiel, from all
the prophets of the Old Testament,
particularly also Daniel.
And many of the symbols that we find in
the Book of Revelation, you will find in
the Book of Daniel.
You will find the terrible beasts in the
Book of Revelation.
And the description of the beasts like
lions, like leopards, like bears, and
terrible beasts with 10 horns, you will
find those in the Book of Daniel.
And you will find the number seven in
the Book of Daniel. If you go through
Daniel chapter seven, for example, you
will have beasts there. If you count up
the heads of the beasts that are
mentioned in Daniel chapter seven,
you'll find seven heads.
And so, you will find seven heads in the
Book of Revelation. So, the picture is
drawn from there. And it is the key to
the Book of Revelation.
Now, unfortunately, we're not going to
go through the Book of Daniel in order
to unlock some of these things. So,
we're just going to say it straight up.
But, there are other videos which have
already been made, which have all the
details as to how these symbolic figures
in the Book of Daniel can be applied to
the Book of Revelation.
So, we'll be dealing with the churches,
the letters, the stars, the
candlesticks. Tonight, we'll be dealing
with the seven churches, for example,
and many of these components will start
to become clear.
Then, there's something else about the
Book of Revelation that's very
fascinating. There's a sanctuary
language in the Book of Revelation. Now,
you know, in the Old Testament, the
Hebrews had to build a sanctuary for
God, and it was very precisely laid out
how the sanctuary had to look, what the
components were. There was a a wall
around it, an outer covering of linen
representing righteousness. There was
one door into the sanctuary. There was
an altar in an outer court where the
offerings were made. There was a laver
where they washed themselves. Then,
there was a compartment which was
divided into two, the first being called
the holy, then the most holy. And the
high priest officiated in the sanctuary.
And this sanctuary language
tells us about the ministry of the high
priest applied to the ministry of the
great high priest who would take the
place of all those that had been
typified in the Old Testament. So, the
sanctuary language is very important
because it tells us where and at what
stage of the ministry this story is
unfolding. So, for example,
when you go Revelation chapters 1 to 3,
you have the story of the seven
churches, Jesus, the light of the world.
There was only one entry way into the
sanctuary. And it was called the gate.
And Jesus says, "I am the door. He who
enters in by me shall have eternal
life."
There is only one door, according to the
Bible, whereby we may be saved. And that
is through Christ Jesus. That's what the
Bible says. Today, that is not a popular
teaching.
And it's going to get less and less
popular as we go along. And we're going
to look at some of these these
teachings. So, for example, the gate,
the doorway, was very, very important in
the Old Testament times. It was the
place where judgment took place. The
elders sat in the gate. The gate was the
doorway behind the walls, whereby you
could enter into safety. There's a lot
of symbolism in the gate.
And Jesus Christ says,
"I am the door.
I am the gate." Now, the old word that
they used for gate was bab.
And there's a story in the Bible about
Babel.
Bab
el,
gate
to God.
So, story of Babel tells us of another
gate to God, another entry way to God,
the bab el, Babel, gate to God. And this
is a story of your own merit bringing
you to God. That is the counterfeit that
we have in the Bible to the biblical
story of saved by the blood of the lamb.
The only way to salvation is through the
merit not of our works,
but through the merit of Jesus Christ.
Those are the two parameters that have
been
in opposition to each other since the
dawn of man, since the fall of man.
Let's put it that way.
So, here, when we're dealing with
lights, the lights were in the first
chamber.
So, that means ministry in the holy.
Uh when we come to Revelation chapter 3
to 8, we're dealing with the seals, and
that is bread of the presence. So, we're
still in that first chamber of the
sanctuary, in the holy place. Then come
the trumpets, Revelation 8 to 11. And
there you can see a golden altar where
you have incense rising from the golden
altar. So, we're still in the holy
place. These are our chambers or events
taking place in a period where the high
high priest representatively
is still serving in that particular
chamber. Soon you get to Revelations
chapter 12 to 14, there's another
picture.
There, the prophet sees the ark of God.
Now, the ark of God was not in the first
chamber of the of the sanctuary. It was
in the second chamber, which was called
the most holy, the hagia hagion, in the
most holy. So, we've moved to another
portion of the ministry of the high
priest. And he only entered into the
place where the ark stood once a year.
And that was on the day of atonement.
Now, these are our heavy subjects, and
we haven't got time to deal with all of
them. Again, there's a video available
on this particular topic of what all
these things meant.
And then in Revelation chapter 15 to 22,
we have what we call eschatology, the
events pertaining to the end, the final
things that will happen on the planet,
those things that have not happened yet
that will happen.
And if you study it in this way, you get
a picture of where you are in the stream
of time.
There are seven blessings in the Book of
Revelation. Blessed is he that readeth,
and they that hear the words of this
prophecy and keep those things which are
written there in, for the time is at
hand. Revelation 1 verse 3. So,
obviously, God wants us to read it,
to hear it,
and to take it to heart because how can
you keep something that you don't
understand, right?
So, when you're looking at this
blessing, isn't it
pretty certain that God wants us to
understand what the Book of Revelation
is about?
Absolutely. So, there's a blessing in
it. So, how's it possible that some say
that it is a sealed book not to be
understood? Well, then you forego this
blessing. Some actually say it is a book
that shouldn't be read because it's for
the damned. Well, if it is for the
damned, then how can there be a blessing
if you read it and take it to heart?
And I heard a voice from heaven saying
unto me, "Write, blessed are the dead
which die in the Lord from henceforth.
Yea, says the Spirit, that they may rest
from their labors, and their works do
follow them." Revelation 14:13. Here's
also an allusion to the works issue.
Works is not a means to salvation. It's
a consequence of salvation.
But, there is a blessing to those that
die in Christ, those who have accepted
the lamb
as their means to salvation, rather than
a bab el, another port to God.
"Behold, I come as a thief. Blessed is
he that watches and keepeth his
garments, lest he walk naked, and they
see his shame.
So, we have to cling to the
righteousness of Christ. We have no
righteousness. Christ is our
righteousness.
And if we give up that idea
and if we give up the hope of his coming
to save those that are his well, then
the chances are that we will walk naked.
Revelation 19:9 and he says unto me,
blessed are they which are called unto
the marriage supper of the Lamb. And he
says unto me, these are true sayings of
God.
Well, obviously there's a blessing in
it. If you are invited to the marriage
supper of the Lamb, that means that you
form part of the bride.
Blessed and holy is he that has part in
the first resurrection. See, there are
two resurrections mentioned in the
Bible. The first resurrection is the
resurrection of those who die in Christ
and they take part in this wedding
feast. And then there is a second
resurrection and they take part in
another feast which is called the supper
of the birds. And I don't think we want
to take part in that one. So, those that
take part in the have a part in the
first resurrection they are the ones
that shall be priests of God and of
Christ and shall reign with him a
thousand years. Here you have the
millennial period.
The seven blessings. Behold, I come
quickly. Blessed is he that keeps the
sayings of the prophecy of this book.
Revelation 22:7. I believe this means
more than just the book of Revelation.
The whole Bible. The Bible is the
standard for the setting of character.
It is the story of salvation.
And blessed are they that do his
commandments that they may have the
right to the tree of life and may enter
in through the gates into the city.
So, obedience to God is a very important
factor as well. Revelation 22:14.
Now, obviously there's going to be a a
counter argument
to all of those factors.
Now, the book of Revelation is written
in a particular structure. We call such
a structure a chiasm. It's a literary
structure which is supposed to set the
events in a particular way in time.
So, for example
if we take the book of Revelation as a
whole, it is written in a in a sort of a
pyramid shape.
And the first parts
are what we call the historic arm, the
seven churches, the seven seals, the
seven trumpets and they lead up to the
great controversy climax between Christ
and Satan and the followers of Satan and
the followers of Christ.
And the second arm, reading from the
back to the middle, would be the New
Jerusalem, the millennium and the fall
of Babylon.
So, this structure tells us where we are
in the stream of time. And if you
understand the structure of the book of
Revelation then it's easier to get
round.
Because
some people like to throw things
all over the place. For example, there
are many who take the trumpets and throw
them into the future, in other words,
into the eschatology. So, they'll take
the trumpets and apply them to events
still to come in in the future when God
restores all things. But then of course
you destroy the chiasm. You cannot
destroy the chiasm.
You can also see where each one of these
fits in
by looking at the sanctuary language.
So, for example, when you're looking at
the churches, the seals and the
trumpets, the language that is used
there still applies to the first
chamber. Now, we'll be dealing with that
as we go along. It doesn't matter if we
don't understand it all at this stage.
So, it tells us historically
where we are in the stream of time so
that we don't jump ahead of ourselves.
We have to stick to the rules. And this
is a marvelous way of getting around in
the book of Revelation. There's a
problem though
because once you've read through the
first half of the book and you come to
the middle, which is basically
Revelation chapter 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
all the way up to 17
that's the sort of final block of the
final events of the battle between good
and evil.
Once you start reading past that, you
are actually reading events in reverse
because the chiasm is structured like
this.
And so it gets very confusing.
You have things in the wrong sequence
and it doesn't make any sense and the
book of Revelation gets so complicated
that you cannot put them into any
particular order. Whereas if you know
that it is a chiasm then you can read
the words as they follow in English, but
the events you put in reverse and then
the whole thing falls into place and it
makes beautiful sense. And the literary
style has has a reason.
It prevents us from becoming disjointed
and jumping all over the place. Now,
let's just have a look at the
how you pick it up so that it's not just
some conjecture that someone makes.
So, for example, if you take the seven
churches
you'll see that in chapter 2:1 it says,
he that holdeth the seven stars walketh
in the midst of the seven candlesticks,
the golden candlesticks. And when you
look at the end of the book of
Revelation, the New Jerusalem
you'll find in chapter 21:23
the Lamb is the light thereof. So, there
you have a light and you have the Lamb
being the light thereof. Chapter 2:7, to
him that overcometh will I give to eat
of the tree of life.
Chapter 22:2,
we have the mention of the tree of life.
So, there you have the chiastic link.
There's an open door in Revelation 3:8
in Revelation 21:25
towards the end you have gates that
never close.
Christ in his father's throne on his
father's throne, Revelation 3:21, 22:1
and 3, the throne of God and of the
Lamb.
The New Jerusalem is mentioned in
chapter 3:12
and the New Jerusalem comes down in
chapter 21:10.
In chapter 3:11, I am coming soon.
Chapter 22:7, I am coming soon. You see
how you pick up the chiasm? How they
stick together? So, you know, all right,
this is how we're working and this is
how we move along.
Now, what's also interesting is that
anything that falls into the first part
of the chiasm must be before the close
of probation.
Because the high priest is ministering
and that means salvation is open to all.
When you come to the eschatology,
probation is closed
because the gates never close anymore.
They are constantly open. The throne of
God has become the throne of God and of
the Lamb. That means Christ reigns in
his kingdom. So, you can pick up where
you are in the stream of time.
So, you cannot make a mistake by putting
things in the wrong place. So, it helps
us to stay within the framework.
When you come to the seven seals and you
pick up the the story there again, the
seven seals are about Christ and his
afflicted people
and you have the resurrected people
enthroned. Here, they are afflicted.
There, they are enthroned. So, obviously
the seven seals falls into which
portion? Probation closed or open?
Probation must still be open because
they are still being afflicted. They are
here on earth. Whereas in the second
part they are enthroned. Their suffering
is over. They have been restored. So,
here you have heaven opened and chapter
19:11, heaven opened. Chapter 6, the
rider on a white horse. Chapter 19, a
rider on a white horse. Chapter 6:9, the
souls of the martyrs ask for judgment.
And in chapter 20, the souls of the
martyrs are resurrected and enthroned as
judges.
In chapter 6 and 7 you hear about white
robes. In chapter 19, they are given
white robes. In chapter 6:15 and 16 he
hears about hears about kings, generals,
etc. They ask to be killed. And here
they are killed again. So, you find the
structure coming together.
Then the book of Revelation contrasts
Christ and his people
with Satan and his followers.
So, you have a trinity of God. You have
the Father, you have the Son and you
have the Holy Spirit.
And if you come to Satan's followers,
you have a false trinity. You have the
dragon
the beast and the false prophet. Now,
the dragon
he represents God the Father. And the
beast you will see in the book of
Revelation, he is the one that takes the
place of Jesus Christ. He's the one that
sets up a kingdom, but it is an earthly
kingdom. He's the one where everybody
bows down to him. Every knee shall bow.
The beast is the one that has a
counterfeit death and a counterfeit
resurrection. He is the false Christ,
the antichristos,
the Antichrist in the place of Jesus
Christ. Because in 75% of cases, the
word Antichrist means in the place of.
We have to know what we're dealing with.
And the false prophet is then obviously
the one who plays the role of the false
Holy Spirit.
And these three powers are going to
deceive the whole world into following a
wrong set of rules and following a wrong
savior.
This is a dangerous story.
And it is so perfectly done and so
deceptive
that if we do not study it in detail,
we will not even know.
Do you think
that the world today might be
largely deceived? Yes or no?
Absolutely. That's what the book of
Revelation talks about. What is it that
Jesus said
when the disciples approached him and
asked him, "What is the sign of your
coming
and of the end of the age?" What is the
first thing that Jesus said? He said,
"Be careful lest anyone
deceive you."
Deception is the name of the game.
In the lectures that are coming now,
we will be dealing with deception like
you have probably never heard it before.
And we're going to deal with some things
which are hair-raising, hair-raising.
So, don't miss the lectures. We're going
to talk about
things that are done in secret. Who does
things in secret?
Yes.
Jesus says, "I have done nothing in
secret." But there are many things that
are done in secret. And this world, make
no mistake, is being run by secret
societies. So, we're going to have a
look at secret societies because the
book of Revelation is about what happens
in secret. All power unto the son, power
unto the beast. See the contrast?
Hebrews Revelation 6:2, all power unto
the son and the counterfeit system, all
power unto the beast.
The keys of death and Hades and the keys
to the bottomless pit. Revelation 9:1
- 18 in Revelation. So, here you have
the contrast between Christ and his
followers
and Satan and his followers. And we will
have to be very meticulous to take these
apart.
Who is like unto the Lord? Isaiah 40:18.
Who is like unto the beast? Revelation
13:4.
So, the beast power,
he's scary.
We have to watch him.
A lamb as it had been slain. Revelation
13:8. One of the heads as it were
wounded to death. Some translations say
seemed to have a mortal wound. He which
is and which was and which is to come.
Revelation 1:4. The beast which was and
is not and is about to come. Revelation
17:8. Can you see the contrast?
So, we're going to deal
in terms of a battle.
And the one that is going to be the
visible component of the battle is going
to be the beast.
But he's hidden.
His name is secret.
And so, we have to look behind the
scenes to find him because that which
you see is not that which is.
That which you see is what you are
supposed to see, but that which you do
not see is what you are not supposed to
see.
And you're not supposed to know about
it.
And that is very important that we find
out what happens behind the scenes.
Then we read in Revelation 6:16 about
the wrath of the lamb. In Revelation
12:12, we read about the wrath of the
devil.
In Revelation 7:2 and 3, God's seal is
in the forehead of those that follow
him, but in Revelation 13, the beast's
mark is in the forehead or in the hand.
Isn't that right? So, we have the
contrast.
We have the name of God in Revelation
14:1 and we have the name of the beast
in Revelation 13:17.
We have the tribes of Israel in
Revelation 1:4 and we have the tribes of
the earth. Revelation 1:7. We have the
armies of heaven. Revelation 19:14. We
have the armies of earth. Revelation
19:19. We have war against Satan and his
people and we have war against Christ
and his followers. Revelation 12:17,
etc. So, there's a battle. This is a
war.
This is a story about a war.
We have a supper of the lamb. We have a
supper of the birds. We have the lamb's
bride. We have the harlot of Babylon. We
have the apostles of the lamb. We have
the false apostles. We have the
Jerusalem of God
and we have Babylon, Satan's church.
And we have the ruler of heaven, earth,
and sea and we have the beast out of the
sea, the beast out of the earth, and the
dragon.
So, we have all these contrasts in the
book of Revelation.
If we read the book of Jeremiah, then we
have a typological story of what this
great battle is all about. You see,
there was a then-time story where there
was a real war between Babylon and the
people of God. And the prophet Jeremiah
is the one who warned against the coming
of Babylon, the coming of Babylon. Did
the people like the message of Jeremiah?
Nope. They didn't like it one little
bit. They lowered him into the cistern.
They beat him up. They put him in
stocks. They did all kinds of terrible
things to poor Jeremiah. They didn't
like the message. Nothing's changed, by
the way.
Jeremiah 2:11, "Has a nation changed
their gods, which are yet not gods?
But my people have changed their glory
for that which does not profit."
This is a battle about God's people.
"Be astonished, O ye heavens, at this
and be horribly afraid. Be ye very
desolate, says the Lord, for my people
have committed two evils. They have
forsaken me,
the fountain of living waters, and have
hewed them out cisterns, broken cisterns
that cannot hold water."
This is a story of what happened in
literal
Jerusalem versus Babylon. Do you think
the same could happen
in our time?
Do you think it's possible? Do you think
the Revelation might be trying to tell
us something?
Jeremiah chapter 2:26, "As the thief is
ashamed when he is found, so is the
house of Israel ashamed.
And they, their kings, their princes,
and their priests, and their prophets
saying to a stock, 'Thou art my father,'
and to a stone,
'Thou hast brought me forth,' for they
have turned their back unto me and not
their faces. But in the time of their
trouble, they will say, 'Arise and save
us.'" So, they're facing east.
They're worshipping a different deity.
"But where are thy gods that thou hast
made thee? Let them arise if they can
save thee in the time of thy trouble.
For according to the number of thy
cities are thy gods, O Judah." So, did
they have many idols? Yes or no?
Yeah. Do you think there will be many
idols in the last days?
I think so.
Deuteronomy 4:28.
"And there you shall serve gods, the
work of men's hands, wood and stone,
which neither see, nor hear, nor eat,
nor smell."
Daniel 5:23, "But has lifted up thyself
against the Lord of heaven and have
brought the vessels of the house before
thee, and thou and thy lords, thy wives,
and thy concubines have drunk wine in
them, and thou hast praised the gods of
silver and gold, of brass and iron, and
wood and stone, which see not, nor hear,
nor know, and the God in whose hands thy
breath is, and whose are all thy ways,
hast thou not glorified." Same thing is
going to happen in our time. So, they
served idols today. Today, we also have
idols.
No difference. Let's just go to ancient
times and I'll run you briefly through
what the structures looked like.
This is an ancient place called Euripus
and uh it's in Syria.
And there are the ruins of an ancient
city. Now, we could go there with this
transport,
but uh it seemed somewhat
flimsy.
So, we opted for this luxury vehicle
over here.
And we drove many, many hundreds of
kilometers with this old Mercedes to
this particular place.
And
that's what it looked like, totally
trashed. You cannot believe that a car
like that can still drive.
And
uh interesting statement on the front
there, "Strong car, faster."
Well, this Arab man took us to this
ancient city.
And here you can find the main gates and
the towers and the houses and the
temples of Adonis and temples of Zeus
and all the ancient citadels. This was a
town after
the formation of Christianity. And in
this town, you had a Christian church.
It's very interesting.
And if you look at the foundations,
that's what it was, just one little
room. And this is obviously where the
Christians met. And in the same town,
you had other temples. So,
people visited the temple of Adonis, for
example. He was the sun. He was
the son of God, if you like.
Here was a counterfeit son of God. And
what did that look like? Well, let me
just see the foundations. So, obviously
here was the building, and you entered
in over here, and there was a central
hall with two side halls on the side.
And here stood pillars separating this
hall from the side halls. And there were
altars in the side halls, and there was
a main altar in the middle. Now, who
builds like that today?
Every single cathedral on the face of
the earth has that structure.
Every single cathedral. Isn't that
interesting? Now, we could go into great
detail there, but we will not.
The Acropolis of Athens is the Yes,
they're all built like that. Exactly.
Uh here is the river Euphrates. So, we
are dealing with uh a nice typology of
Babylon, if you like. Here were steps
leading up to the temple of Zeus, the
father of the gods.
And if you go to Syria, then the most
famous one, of course, was the great
goddess of the fountains. And uh this is
the city where they're digging this up,
Mari.
And uh they're finding some very
interesting things down there. They
built with clay, for example, clay
bricks. The Bible tells us that Babylon
was constructed with clay bricks. Here
you have the temple of Bacchus.
This is in Lebanon.
And fascinating what you find there.
This is a pillar.
A huge pillar found at Baalbek. This was
the largest pillar in the world until
they found the other one. This one was
discovered in '93.
And you can see the size of the the man
next to it over there.
And uh that's me. I'm just, you know,
picking it up there. No no sweat.
No, no.
It's huge.
You cannot imagine the size of these
structures. These are actually not
pillars. Here's one that was rejected.
There's a man standing over there as a
scale.
And uh they transported these and built
them into their temples. There's one of
them lying over there. The foundation
stones down here are these huge blocks
of stone. How they transported them,
nobody knows. This is the Bacchus
temple.
And uh it used to be the temple of Baal.
That's why the town is still called
Baalbek. I'm giving you some history of
the apostasy in the past, so that we can
compare it with the present.
Here at Baalbek, you have this temple of
Bacchus. Here is the temple of Jupiter
with its six pillars still standing.
Very, very beautiful.
And uh the sun striking the pillars. It
was a system of sun worship.
Of course, Bacchus, the god of
drunkenness and revelry.
Maybe this pillar had a had a little bit
too much to drink, I don't know.
And uh if you go in to the altar of
Jupiter, for example, you found this
structure. This is exactly what the god
Quetzalcoatl looks like in South
America.
So, you know where the South American uh
religion came from.
Then you had Venus with winged lions on
the side. The Bible talks about the lion
with eagle wings as a symbol of Babylon.
And you had this structure over here,
the circle with a cross in it. Was a
symbol of Baal. You'll find it in many,
many churches today.
If you go to the Jupiter temple further,
you will find some interesting
structures, lions again, certain reliefs
on the uh pillars. You had these
swastikas all over. They were a symbol
of sun worship. There they are, somewhat
enlarged. You'll find the same swastika
under the foot of Buddha.
Buddhism uses exactly the same symbol
that was used in the temple of Baal.
Uh you'll find it on uh Roman reliefs in
ancient times. There you will find it
even in the time of the Hittites, the
swastika. You'll find the symbol of the
circle with a dot in it used in the
past.
Uh you will find altars
and uh
sacrificial pillars, three arches with
three deities in it. Normally, they
would have the father, the mother, and
the child in them.
Here you have another interesting symbol
that is used today.
Uh
owls and
uh falcons, very popular.
And interesting structures like this
one, for example. What would you say
that structure was?
It looks like the star of David, doesn't
it?
Now, all the star of David has nothing
to do with David, and I will you will
not find a star of David in the Bible.
This is a star that was used even in the
times of the Hittites. It's a symbol of
Baal. You'll find that Islam uses it.
There's the name Allah in the hexagram.
And here you will find Om in it.
Hinduism uses it. Was used in Baal
worship. The half moon with a star in
it,
or the sickle moon,
as is used in Islam, there you'll find
it amongst the Hittites.
This symbol over here,
well, there you find it being used in
NATO, by NATO today. Angels.
Pigs, a woman with a mini dress on,
with a golden cup in her hand. These are
symbols that tell us that the symbolism
in the temples of Baal
was identical to the symbolism used in
the Book of Revelation and in the world
today.
And we are going to compare
in this
time that we're going to spend together,
what happened then
and what is happening today.
A great apostasy towards God existed in
the past.
A great apostasy exists today.
Christ is being dethroned today as he
was dethroned in the past. It is time to
put him back into the center and give
him the rightful place, which is
rightfully his.
In our previous session, we looked at
some of the symbols that you found in
the temples of Baal and the temples of
Bel. And a very interesting symbol was
this one over here that you find in
Baalbek, in the temple of Baal. It's a
woman
with a cup in her hand.
Now, the Book of Revelation speaks about
a woman that rides the beast that has a
golden cup in her hand.
Fascinating to find them in the various
places.
If you go to these temples, you will
find that they were temples of death.
You will always find
tombs in them and bones. Did you know
that there is not a cathedral in the
world where you will not walk on the
corpses of men?
No cathedral may be built without dead
bodies. In fact, every cathedral
is a cemetery.
And you cannot say a mass in a cathedral
or in a church if there is not a relic
of a dead individual in that particular
building. So, if you walk into the great
cathedrals, you are walking on the
bodies of men.
If you went to the temples of Baal, you
will find little angels.
Where in the Bible do you read about
little angels?
Nowhere. Nowhere.
Angels
are described in the Bible as masculine
and of great power
and magnificent beings.
In the temple of Baal, they were reduced
to tiny little cupid-like angels, fat
little angels. There they are, in the
Baal temple. Where do you find them
today?
You'll find them in all the churches.
Now, let's have a look up here.
Interesting symbolism up against the
ceiling. Let's draw it a little bit
closer. You'll find the eagle standing
on a key.
There are many churches that use this
symbolism today.
There you have
the great god Osiris with wings
and the pine cones.
And you'll find the gods and the
goddesses of licentiousness, if you
like, within
the hexagrams and the hexagons. And
you'll find the hexagrams and the
hexagons on the ceilings of the temples
of Baal, like you can see them over
there.
If you look up.
This is the city of palms, Palmyra.
And it has the longest column that's
still in existence today. Even today,
there are palm trees over there.
And this is the longest Roman colonnade
still existing.
And if you look at it, it is
magnificent. And if you look into the
back there, you'll see the Temple of
Bel.
Now, the word Bel today is used by
industry exclusively.
Uh and you'll find many, many allusions
to Bel in the world today.
There is the Temple of Bel. This is the
best preserved Temple of Bel in the
world. Basically, another form of Baal.
And if that's the courtyard on the
outside, and that was the place where
they did their offering. They also had a
holy place and a most holy place. It was
structured
on the same plan
basically as that of Israel.
But, of course, Satan is an angel fallen
from heaven, and he had the plan as
well. So, his is a counterfeit of the
heavenly story. If you look up against
the ceiling, you have sun symbols, and
you have palm trees,
and you have these deities represented
as pine cones and pomegranates and
pineapples. And uh you'll find halos
around them around the sun deities.
Again, you will find feathers and and uh
eagles
and interesting things up against the
walls, which we don't even have to talk
about. This is a very interesting one.
This is the flame of Lucifer. This is
the flame of Bel. What's it look like?
Looks exactly like an Olympic torch.
Exactly like an Olympic torch. In fact,
they just lit one the other day, if you
watched television, and they said a
prayer to whom?
Apollo.
The sun god.
It's not dead today. It's just
disguised.
Of course, you have the grapes for
Bacchus. You have the fleur-de-lis and
the the triangles and the sphinxes with
their breasts, female representations.
There is one.
And uh angels with wings amongst the
pine cones.
And here is the upside down triangle
with eagles in it. This symbolism is
used today
in all the mighty political entities of
the world. So, we have a lot of things
to look at in the Book of Revelation.
The eagle in its various forms is the is
the symbol of many, many nations.
So, the Book of Revelation
is going to tell us
about this great conflict between good
and evil. This great conflict between
idolatry
and the worship of the true God.
And we're going to look at things
which will stun you.
We're going to look at the intricacies
of the workings behind the scenes. How
the world today is really moving towards
the enthronement
of another power. And the Book of
Revelation warns us about these things.
So, now let's go through the first
chapter verse by verse.
The Revelation of Jesus Christ, which
God gave unto him to show unto his
servants the things which must shortly
come to pass.
Wonderful.
So, he's going to tell us ahead of time
what's going to happen. Now, if someone
has the power to tell you accurately
ahead of time what's going to happen,
isn't that somebody that you could
trust?
I would say so.
In fact, prophecy
changed me from being an atheist
to being a believer.
And experience
taught me
to follow Christ. He's not just on
paper. He's real.
He's believable.
He's trustworthy.
His promises are yay and amen.
He says, "I will never leave you nor
forsake you." And I have found him to be
trustworthy.
And he sent
shortly come to pass, and he sent and
signified it by his angel unto his
servant John.
So, John is now receiving this
revelation. Who bear record of the word
of God and of the testimony of Jesus
Christ and of all things that he saw.
So, even though we are going to talk
about terrible, terrible things in the
lectures to come,
and I'm telling you again, it'll be like
you have never heard it before. And
people might say to me,
"Why are you concentrating
on what the evil side is doing?
Why not just talk about Jesus?"
I wish I could do that.
I wish I could talk
just about Jesus.
But, there's a problem.
How would you feel
if you had a child
that you really, really love? Let's talk
about love.
Let's say you had a child and you
really, really loved that child.
But, you know that that child
is busy
with wrong things. And that that child
is going to be destroyed if it carries
on along that path.
How would you feel?
What would you do?
It's no point saying to the child,
"Mommy loves you."
Because the child is infatuated with
whatever it's doing.
Surely, if your child is on drugs, it's
very important to show the child that
you love the child. But, isn't it also
important to warn the child? Yes or no?
Yes. So, what do we do when we do this?
We educate the child on what?
On the dangers of drugs, right?
And we tell the child, "This is what's
going to happen, this, that, that, and
the other."
Do they listen?
No, something else has to happen in the
heart. But, these things are important
for the child to make a decision in the
end.
Or what if you find your child joining
some
I don't know, some vicious group that
eventually will lead to the child's
destruction.
Wouldn't you like to tell the child that
here and here and here and here is the
deception of what this particular
organization or group is doing? Yes or
no?
Wouldn't you want to save that child out
of all those problems?
So, yes. Unfortunately, it is so
that there are many deceptions in many
things that lead on the broad path to
destruction. And we're going to have to
reveal them. And that is painful. And
it's going to be talking about the
negative.
But, why do we do it?
Because we want people to choose the
positive.
And if we can take all the parameters in
the world,
and we can say, "This one is deceptive
because of this. That one because of
this. This one because of that."
Eventually,
only one remains.
And that's Jesus Christ.
So, basically,
what we are doing is we are going to
follow a process of exclusion.
We're going to look at the various
components of Babylon.
And then maybe we'll discover that all
of us have been trapped.
All of us have been lied to.
Every single one of us as we sit here
today
has been deceived. It's a terrible
thought.
But, in the end, it crystallizes out
that there's only one that can be
trusted.
And that is Jesus Christ. And he alone
can save you. I am the door.
I am the way. I am the word.
He who believes in me shall never
perish. That's what he said. Either it's
the truth
or it's a lie.
If the world wants to come together
and join one big happy family,
and we all have to tolerate every single
thing that is being taught in the world,
is that truth or is it truth mingled
with error?
You tell me.
So, we have to find out whether all
paths lead to God
or whether only one path leads to God.
And we have to decide on the basis of
that.
So, bear record of the word of God and
of the testimony of Jesus Christ and of
all things that he saw. The word of God
and the prophecies of the Bible, we'll
have to understand them.
Blessed is he that readeth and that hear
the words of the prophecy and keep the
things that are written therein, for the
time is at hand. Revelation 1:3, verse
4. John, to the seven churches which are
in Asia. We're going to deal with them
in the next lecture in detail.
Grace be unto you and peace from him
which is and which was and which is to
come.
And from the seven spirits which are
before his throne. Now, obviously, the
Bible teaches that there is one God,
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit. So, the
number seven here
is the number of perfection. Also, we'll
see that there are seven time periods.
He's going to discuss the events over
time periods divided into seven. So, the
seven spirits before God is one spirit
of God, perfect number seven in all time
throughout history, one spirit.
So, we mustn't get confused and have
more spirits than they are, because the
Bible has to be in harmony with itself.
And then the greatest part about
Revelation chapter 1
is it tells us who and what the author
is.
And it's written in an amazing fashion.
It's written in a way which is called an
epanados. Now, an epanados is like a
chiasm
except that instead of describing
events, it quotes in a certain sequence.
So, for example,
this epanados consists of a series of
quotes which want to highlight a
particular point.
Isaiah chapter 55 verse 4, you read
about the witness. And it's a quote
from
It's Revelation 1:5 and it's a quote
from Isaiah.
And if you go to the end of it, there's
another quote in Revelation 1:16, which
is also from Isaiah.
Then there is another point, the second
point mentioned, Revelation 1:7 talks
about the coming with the clouds. It's a
quote from Daniel chapter 7:13.
And then you have one at the end here,
Revelation 1:13, where it talks about
the priest, and it's a quote from Daniel
7:9. And so, the first and the last is
from Isaiah, the second and the second
last is from Daniel, the third and the
third last is from Zechariah, and then
there are two in the middle.
That lifts out the central theme. That's
an epanados.
And the central theme is I am the Alpha
and the Omega. If you take one away, you
don't have an epanados. There must be
two in the middle.
So, some Bibles have the Bible repeats
itself. Why say this twice?
Take out the one.
We destroy the structure. You cannot
take one word out of the Bible
or you're in trouble.
Man shall not live by bread alone, but
by
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of the Lord.
Well, we better make sure we read all of
it. All of it. Whole lecture coming on
that topic. Fascinating stuff. Anyway,
the Book of Revelation chapter 1 proves
that Jesus Christ is the great I Am.
He is God.
Now, that's a problem today.
That's a problem.
Because if Jesus is God
and if Jesus is the way, the truth, and
the life, and if Jesus is the only way
whereby you can be saved, well, then you
have a problem.
If you want to be
in the same pot with all the other
religions of the world.
Because Jesus has to become a little bit
less
in order to fit into the same level
as all the others. Now, we have a
problem.
Obviously, the world cannot afford one
group to say that it has a superior
religion over any other group. Would you
agree with me in the world that we're
living today? You cannot have that.
So, Jesus has to be made a little bit
less
so that the others can be a little bit
more. How do you achieve that?
You create the pain of exclusiveness.
In other words, you make it so painful
to be exclusive that you'd rather choose
to be less exclusive. Does that make
sense?
Think about that.
Either he is what he says he is or he is
not what he says he is. And from Jesus
Christ, who is the faithful witness and
the first begotten of the dead, and the
prince of the kings of the earth, unto
him that loved us and washed us from our
sins in his own blood. Does this tell us
what Jesus is all about? Yes or no?
Is this exclusive and special or is this
something on a par with everyone else?
I'm not knocking any other religion. I'm
just asking.
Is Jesus on a par with, let's say,
Buddha?
In this particular text, yes or no?
Is he on a par with a Zoroaster?
Is he on a par with Shiva?
Yes or no? Osiris? Yes or no?
No.
Because this one's different.
He loved us. He washed us. He's the King
of kings. He's the Prince of all of
them.
And he's the only one who can save
because he's the only one who is what?
God.
Do you know what the difference is
between Christianity and all the other
religions of the world?
The difference is that Christ's tomb is
empty.
Christianity
is the only religion on the face of the
earth that gives a reason for the state
of the planet, the mess we're in.
And it's the only religion on the face
of the earth that has a solution to the
problem.
All the other religions find their
solution in their own works, and if they
don't succeed, now try, try, and try
again through various reincarnations
until you finally get it right. Is it
getting better or is it getting worse?
And obviously not doing too well at it,
right?
So, Christianity gives a reason
and it gives a solution.
And it tells us why
and it tells us how. There's no other
religion on the face of the earth that
does this.
And Christianity
has the word of God,
which is the infallible word of God,
which has been attacked at every single
level, from the scientific level right
through to the historic level, to the
level of the salvation.
And you know what?
The Bible has stood the test of time.
It's the only book on the face of the
earth that has been vindicated
scientifically,
archeologically, historically,
and in terms of its salvation premise.
It picks people up from where they are
and changes them into something else.
There is no other book like it. And even
if the whole world teaches something
else, as they are at the moment, believe
me, they do,
then pick up those videos about creation
and evolution and have a look at them.
Make up your mind on the base of the
scientific facts.
I was a professor at the university for
more than 30 years.
And I was professor of zoology.
And I was probably the only one in
secular university
that didn't believe in evolution.
That took some doing.
And he has made us kings and priests
unto God and his father. To him be glory
and dominion forever and ever.
Behold, he comes with the clouds, and
every eye shall see him, and they also
which pierced him, and all kindred of
the earth shall wail because of him.
Even so, amen.
In other words, rather than having this
sumptuous joy at the coming of Christ,
most of them will what?
Wail.
Here's a different story to what is
being taught even in the world of
Christianity, where everybody is waiting
for the restoration of the kingdom and a
second chance.
Some believe, "No, we don't even have to
wait for every eye to see them, because
we'll be raptured away."
Does the Bible teach that?
I am the Alpha and the Omega. There's
the center of the epanados. The
beginning and the ending, says the Lord,
which is and which was and which is to
come, the Almighty.
That's pretty straight talk.
Jesus Christ in the Book of Revelation
is identified not just as King of kings,
the Savior of the world, but he is
identified as God.
If we make Jesus Christ any less than he
is,
then I'm afraid we have no savior.
Because then that savior would be in the
same boat that we are in.
So, he's God.
I, John, who also am your brother and
companion in tribulation and in the
kingdom and patience of Jesus Christ,
was in the isle of called Patmos for the
word of God.
So, if you preach the word, you're in
trouble.
And for the testimony of Jesus Christ,
which is the prophetic word over all
time.
So, if you preach prophecy, you're going
to get into trouble.
So, are you all prepared for what's
coming?
We're going to look at some of these
things, and it's scary.
We're going to look at very interesting
things.
I was in the spirit on the Lord's day
and heard behind me a great voice as of
a trumpet. Revelation 1:8-10.
So, on what day was he in the spirit?
I was in the spirit on the Lord's day.
Revelation 1:10.
If thy turn thy foot away from the
Sabbath, from doing thy pleasure on my
holy day, and call the Sabbath a
delight, the holy of the Lord honorable.
Isaiah 58:13. It's the only one that is
called the holy day of the Lord.
So, obviously, he was in spirit on the
Sabbath day.
But Mark also talks about the fact that
the Son of man is Lord also of the
Sabbath. So, obviously, he in vision on
this day, on the Sabbath day, and God
showed him what was going to happen in
the world.
Saying, "I am Alpha and Omega, the first
and the last, and what thou seest, write
in a book and send it unto the seven
churches which are in Asia." Now, I'm
not going to deal with the details
because I'm going to deal with them in
the next lecture.
Unto Ephesus,
Smyrna,
Pergamos,
Thyatira,
Sardis,
Philadelphia,
Laodicea. Each name
has a particular meaning.
Even the location has a meaning.
Revelation 1:11,
"And I turned to see the voice that
spoke with me, and being turned, I saw
seven golden candlesticks."
Where does he see Jesus?
In which chamber does he see Jesus?
He sees him in the holy place. So,
obviously, we have a time setting. The
ministry of the high priest is taking
place in the holy place, not in the most
holy holy. So, this is not Yom Kippur,
the day of judgment. This is prior
to the final judgment. So, we are
historically
in a time before the close of probation,
Jesus is ministering in the holy place.
That's where he sees him.
Because he sees him ministering amongst
the seven candlesticks. Historically,
that's important. So, if you look at the
old postal route, and you look at the
various cities, Ephesus, Smyrna,
Pergamum, Thyatira,
Sardis, Philadelphia, Laodicea, that's
the old postal route, and we're going to
deal with that in the next lecture. So,
he has this great vision of ministering
between seven golden candlesticks. And
the candlestick stands for the light of
the world. Jesus is the light of the
world. Revelation 1:13,
"And in the midst of the seven
candlesticks, one like unto the Son of
man." Jesus, the high priest, the
ministering high priest. He's the one
who is the light of the world. He's the
one who is the bread from heaven, the
bread of the presence. He is the one
that mediates on your behalf. He is the
altar of incense, and the incense rising
up is the ministry of Christ in making
our prayers acceptable through God to
God through his mediation. He is the one
who deals and works in us to change our
hearts of stone to hearts of flesh.
That's the picture that we have of a
caring Jesus Christ who is in control,
who knows exactly what's going to
happen, and foretells us in detail how
he permits
apostasy
to take on the form that it is even in
our time.
Now, you know, this amazes me. If I were
God,
there would be a problem. Thank God I'm
not God.
Because I wouldn't have the patience
that he has
to deal with apostasy the way he does.
And how he permits it
to grow
and to reach fruit so that everyone can
see it for what it is. By the way, if
you look at the world out there today,
is it a pleasant place?
No, it's not a pleasant place.
In some countries,
I come from South Africa,
our houses are like jails.
Murders left, right, and center. 4,000
farmers already murdered. Believe that
or not.
It's horrendous what's happening.
And nobody even knows. If you take a
country like Zimbabwe, they're just
driving them off the lands.
And there is no sanctity of anything
anymore.
We're living in really terrible times.
It is not safe for a young girl, it is
not safe for a young man these days
to go jogging alone.
What kind of world are we living in?
And if you look at the horrendous things
that are done in the world today,
sometimes you wonder, how can God permit
this?
God is permitting
sin and apostasy
to ripen to the point where everybody
will see what it means to choose against
God's
righteous ways and man's ways.
And that is an act of love. And in the
midst of the fear and the confusion,
there's a quiet place where he calls and
he says,
"Come unto me,
you who are wearied and heavy laden, and
I will give you
rest."
So, we can find peace in the midst of
confusion.
And we can choose. We can choose to walk
through life and look at the thorns and
the briars and the thistles,
or we could choose to look at the
flowers and the lilies and the beautiful
fruit. The choice is ours.
And if we choose the one, we will choose
sadness. If we choose the other one, in
the midst of sadness, we can have peace.
And that's what Jesus Christ is all
about. He is the one in the midst of the
candlesticks. He is the light of the
world. But the candlesticks represents
the churches that are to carry the light
to the world throughout all the ages.
And in the midst of the seven
candlesticks, one like unto the Son of
man, clothed with a garment down to his
foot and girt about perhaps with a
golden girdle. I'm quoting the King
James, so sometimes it sounds a bit
old-fashioned,
but uh
at least we have all the words there.
His hair His head and his hair were
white like wool, as white as snow. His
eyes were as the flame of fire. Nothing
escapes him. Perfect righteousness. His
feet like unto fine brass, as if they
burned in a furnace, and his voice as
the sound of many waters. Revelation
1:13-15. This was the voice of God.
Jesus is described as God, not a created
being.
He was the one that was and that is and
that is to come from all eternity. The
one who initiated the process of
creation.
The one who spoke and it stood fast.
That's how he is described here. The
vision that we have of him here is the
one that Daniel had. Ezekiel described
him like this. He is seeing Yahweh.
That's who he is seeing.
"And he had in his right hand seven
stars, and out of his mouth went a sharp
two-edged sword." It's the word of God.
"And his countenance was as the sun
shineth in his strength." So, there you
have the true Son of righteousness and
the me feeble counterfeit is sun
worship.
"And when I saw him, I fell at his feet
as dead, and he laid his right hand upon
me, saying unto me, 'Fear not.
I am the first and the last.' And if you
take one message home tonight, it's this
one.
In spite of what we're going to deal
with in the lectures,
fear not.
"I am the first and the last. I am he
that liveth and was dead, and behold, I
am alive forevermore. Amen. And I have
the keys of hell and of death." He's the
only one who can save you.
And he has promised to do it.
"Write the things which thou
hast seen,
the things which are,
and the things which shall be
hereafter." Here's a key.
How do we interpret what the Book of
Revelation is going to say? It deals
with what you have seen, which is right
now.
So,
which are. The prophet is looking at
visions, and they apply
to that time.
"And the things which shall be
hereafter." What's that?
Future. So, how do we read the Book of
Revelation?
Surely,
if that is the key, then that applies to
what happened then,
throughout history, into the future. Yes
or no?
God is fair.
Is he going to write a book and put it
in his Bible and give it to every
generation and say, "Here's a book that
is not for you. Where, where, where?
It's only for those who live in a couple
of thousand years"?
Or is God going to put information for
every generation in his book? Yes or no?
God is just. He's fair.
But we have whole groups today which
take the Book of Revelation and apply it
only to the future.
In fact, to a generation that will not
even be here
when it happens.
In fact, to a whole church that will be
gone and raptured when it is supposed to
happen. Does that make any sense?
No.
The Book of Revelation
is historic
continuous.
What happened then is applicable to the
people living then, what happened in the
next generation is applicable to them,
and we have the whole story all the way
through to the end. It applies to us
all.
And particularly, of course,
to the great culminating events in the
history of time. The mystery of the
seven stars which thou sawest in my
right hand important important
because on the right are the
saved, on the left are the
damned.
And the seven golden stand candlesticks,
the seven stars are the angels. Angel is
a messenger
of the seven churches, the seven
churches of God in time periods, the
preachers, if you like, those carrying
the message. They are in the right hand
of God. He's in control. In spite of
what's happening, remember God is in
control.
And the seven candlesticks which thou
sawest are the seven churches. God has
this amazing ministry
that he uses fallen man
to preach the word. Wow. He could have
done it himself. He could have thundered
it from heaven. He could have used
angels,
but he uses us.
That's incredible.
So, the ministry of Christ in the
heavenly sanctuary,
if you look at the great story of how it
all happened, when Christ rose from the
dead, where did he go when he rose to
the rose from the dead, he went up into
heaven to serve in the sanctuary, says
the
Book of Hebrews, in a heavenly
sanctuary. So, we have a heavenly
ministry. We won't be dealing with the
details in this particular lecture, and
it stretches from then to the end of
time. And it's divided up in the
sanctuary language where you have all
the symbols like the candlesticks and
the bread and the altar of incense in
the first chamber and the second
chamber, and then we know where we are
in the stream of time so that we don't
get lost in the Book of Revelation.
And he said unto me, "Unto 2,300
days, then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed." Daniel 8:14.
So, it goes right up to a particular
time in history. We're not dealing with
this prophecy, either. There's a whole
lecture on it, and you can find it in uh
one of the tapes.
But just a little bit of background, in
Daniel 8, we have the story of an
unfolding of an amazing prophecy.
So, he came near where I stood, this
angel, and when he came, I was afraid
and fell on my face, but he said unto
me, "Understand, oh son of man, for that
at the time of the end shall be the
vision." Not the end of time, the time
of the end.
And while I was speaking in prayer, the
man Gabriel, the angel, came to me in
swift flight, and he said to me, "Oh
Daniel, I have now come to out to give
you wisdom and understanding."
And then he proceeds to give a most
amazing prophecy, which is a Messianic
prophecy.
The most perfect prophecy that you can
possibly imagine. It gives the time when
the Messiah should come so accurately
that in the Talmud you read,
"May the bones of the hands and the
bones of the fingers decay and decompose
of him who turns the pages of the Book
of Daniel
to find out the time of Daniel 9:24-27."
This is written in the Talmud.
"And may his memory rot from off the
face of the earth forever."
Talmudic law, page 978, section 2.
Why would the Jewish Talmud contain such
a curse for someone who tries to number
the time of Daniel 9:24-27?
I'll tell you why.
Because it tells you exactly when the
Messiah will come.
It tells you exactly what the Messiah
will do. We're not dealing with this
prophecy in detail. As I said, there is
a whole video on it. You can get it if
you want to. There's also a book written
on it.
So, the fact of the matter is that only
one Messiah in the history of mankind
applies, and that's Jesus Christ.
No one else.
And if they were to accept Daniel
9:24-27,
what would have to happen with the
Jewish religion?
It would have to become the Christian
religion.
And it would disappear off the face of
the earth.
Something that they do not want.
And so, rather curse the one who uses
it.
It tells us when a decree would go
forth.
It tells us when the Messiah would would
start his ministry. It tells us when the
Messiah would die, 31 AD, and it tells
us when the gospel would go to the
Gentiles. Amazing prophecy. It's a
2,300-year
prophecy dealing with this tremendous
time period from the issuing of the
decree to restore Jerusalem all the way
until the time of judgment. There's a
date there, 1844, because the 2,300-day
prophecy, if you add it all together,
2,300 years from there. In the Bible, it
tells us in the Book of Numbers that and
in the Book of Ezekiel that you can take
a day for a prophetic year.
Then you get to a interesting date which
we will deal with in another lecture,
far too complicated to deal with it now.
And then there is a time which the Bible
calls the time of the end, and we are
living in that time right now. And then
he went
one time, we will come to the point of
eternity.
And the Bible teaches that Jesus is
following the same ministry that was
typified in that sanctuary service on
earth. Hebrews 9:11, "But Christ being
come a high priest of good things to
come by a greater and more perfect
tabernacle not made with hands."
That is to say, not of this building,
not an earthly one.
"Neither by the blood of goats
and calves, but by his own blood he
entered in once into the holy place,
hagion,
having obtained eternal redemption for
us." Very important point. That's what
the King James says.
Some modern translations don't like
this, so they've changed this to most
holy place. Big problem. Because now the
whole ministry of Christ is But that's a
complicated story. We'll deal with it.
Can't be holy place. It has to mean
can't be most holy place. Must be holy
place because if it were most holy, it
wouldn't say hagion, it would say hagia
hagion, which it doesn't say. It says
there, which actually means sanctuary.
Hebrews 9:12, "Not with the blood of
goats and calves, but with his
own blood." So, this ministry could only
start
once Jesus had died.
So, Jesus must have entered the
sanctuary to start his ministry only
after his death, which means he entered
into the first chamber and not into the
second chamber because the high priest
only entered that once a year. And in
the Book of Revelation, where do we see
Jesus serving in chapter 1?
Where the candlesticks are. So, why are
they trying to twist the Bible here and
there? Complicated thoughts, just put
them in the back of your mind, don't
worry about them. We don't have to
understand everything first shot. We'll
get to that later. Get clearer. Hebrews
9:3, "And after the second veil, the
tabernacle which is called the holiest
of all, hagia hagion, the high priest
went once a year." Now, it was a
different story. And
when did Jesus do that? Obviously,
sometime after his resurrection.
So, the question I have to you tonight
is if we have a high priest,
and if that high priest is God,
and if that high priest is the only one
who through his blood can save you,
then we have to choose him over all
others.
If there is no other name under heaven
and earth whereby you may be saved, then
we have to choose him over all others.
But I have news for you.
If you do,
you will get into trouble sooner or
later.
Either in the immediate circle or in the
greater circle.
But as for me and my house,
I have decided to serve the Lord,
and I would like to invite you to do the
same.
Thank you.
>> Oh.